johanna orlando winning an Oscar I guess
is a pretty big thing even though I met
some guys back backstage who said that
there are other prizes you can win an
Academy Award I guess is sort of similar
to being the world champion and that
means that you should be the world
champion of documenting the truth but
whose truth is it that you're actually
documenting in a documentary like this I
mean I think it really depends you know
documentary is as a whole is going from
strength to strength in recent times and
partly because of in a confusion or
weakness in traditional journalism I
think there are many documentarians out
there that really focus on the talents
of journalism and and telling a deeper
truth than we've been used to but those
are not always necessarily just facts
sometimes that's emotional sometimes
that's historical and documentary has a
very particular form of truth-telling
but do you think it's is it your truth
or is it the truth um what helmets or
it's what we would call an emotional
truth or an essential truth and then on
the other hand a journalistic truth what
we're not interested in talking about is
a literal truth now a literal truth in
filmmaking form might be a shot of mr.
Smith a man walking onto a train now but
what we're interested in is the
essential truth which would be that mr.
Smith is actually walking on onto that
train because he's having an affair with
his best friend's wife that's at the
heart of documentary it's about
understanding human behaviors and
getting at a deeper truth but running
alongside that is what is very much part
of our work is also grounding this
emotional and essential truth in
journalistic troops which are built on a
discipline
of verifying facts from multiple sources
so on the one hand we're storytellers
but we're also very much journalists is
it difficult to balance that or do you
find it easy for you to find the right
sort of storytelling part of it and the
fact part of course it's difficult
nothing that was ever worth it was was
easy but I think that we choose to tell
the stories of the unheard all those who
are under attack and in some way balance
out then the narratives that are
happening you said when we talked a lot
this morning about those who hold the
power and may lie and part of our work
is how do we address the balance there
for those voices you don't have that
power and may have truth that is not
being heard there's a difficult to know
which voices to listen to and not always
but you know that's where we sit in the
talents of journalism to make sure that
we are fact-checking and doing our
homework properly you have to make sure
that when you are especially if you are
representing those who are
underrepresented that you are doing it
properly that you cannot be just solely
swayed by the emotion of their story
although you know an individual's
emotional pathway is still a real truth
even if theirs is not representative of
everybody's truth rather than and how do
you go about when you decide which but
which stories and hence which truth that
you want to tell I mean you know I think
that the truth is well maybe if I talk
about what we're drawn to we're drawn to
stories which inspire us were drawn to
stories often of people who have decided
to put their head above the parapet and
do something different and risk their
lives and in the case of the white
helmets this was a group of of men and
women who had decided not to flee Syria
had decided not to pick up a gun and had
decided every day to go out and risk
their lives to save others so and we
thought that was in this case was a
story that could engage people in in
this severe crisis said that that's what
we're driven by they're the stories
which inspire us and but then of course
we have to when we start to investigate
that story and we start to make it we
are ground
and confined by the journalism and
everything we do is is set against that
integrity I read somewhere that you
Gianna actually call yourself an
activist I guess an activist for good
courses and how do you balance that if
you're an activist then you really want
to achieve change when I think I think
most filmmakers storytellers even
journalists you know understand that
they come to a conclusion at the end
perhaps no different to a scientist you
have to base it in the facts but at the
end you then have a professional opinion
about what is happening and it's no
different for me that means that you
know when we go into Sur and we look at
the white helmets we will obviously read
all of the stories and hear the
narrative from the Syrian government
that the white helmets are not real that
no civilians are killed there you know
that they actually you know everything
all is well in Syria and we have to go
in fact check that against the stories
that we're hearing from the white
helmets and others and then make an
opinion and once you make that opinion
then you feel very strongly that you
have to back that and you have to push
it out into the world if that makes me
an activist then yes I am was it obvious
for you to choose film as your language
it's variable it's a very powerful
medium and one that gets to many many
people and again when we're talking
about the rebalancing of asymmetric
power you have to use the tools that are
in your armory to do that and film is a
very powerful way of doing that maybe
just to follow up on that just just very
briefly dr. gross at the beginning of
this was was talking about science
having a battle against against liars I
would say that one thing science needs
to think about is how to tell stories
better perhaps to fight that because
there are amazing stories grounded in
science and I think if you can find the
right people and characters and use film
as a medium you have a grounding for for
beating the false truths Alice you have
a pretty uncommon background I would say
for being a politician and I think and I
hope that you would be proud if I would
call you an activist why did you choose
the political path to get as your way of
changing the world or improving the
world well I think
comes in many different forms and and
for me being an activist in the fair
trade movement and in in save the
children and human rights organizations
I came to the conclusion that I also
wanted to take holistic responsibility
and Sweden is a parliamentary democracy
which is a great I mean it's a great
opportunity for all of us to really want
to change the society and I felt that I
have had to go from having this one
issue focused to really see how can I
make real society change holistically so
that's why I chose to to be a politician
was it the right decision yes are you
sure yes I mean we you need to be all of
us social changes we need to be
everywhere we need to be in in civil
society and organization but we also
need the people in politics in our
parliamentary systems and this that's
one of our biggest challenges for us
from the politics to make sure that
people want to be part of this holistic
responsibility too I think you just said
that politicians are lying and that is
one one of the reasons why you didn't
say all but you said that politicians
are lying politicians are lying
politicians are lying
oh no but that that of course is part of
the call it the balance or call it the
energy between you could call it media
journalism and politicians but on this
same same time you are very dependent
upon each other they are the people that
you are sort of documenting but you are
also dependent upon the politicians when
it comes to creating an infrastructure I
mean look you know when society is
healthy the media and Parliament's exist
in a in a good way the oxygen is is well
flowing you know politicians are telling
the truth the media documents that in a
correct way that's unbiased and that's
how the public you know creates a
mandate for the politicians to continue
or to choose which policies they
understand now that's when it's healthy
we're in a current situation well things
aren't healthy and we have we have
situations like what's happening in the
u.s. we have what's happening in the UK
with bread cert you know the British
public we're told a series of lies about
about Greg Suhr and and subsequently
voted you know to leave Europe but must
be fantastic for journalists and for
documentary filmmakers having the
material you have there well yes you
know and I very much we're not covering
that that issue but you know I hate very
much hope there's a documentarian there
is because there is a responsibility for
the media to point out when that system
is not healthy and when the politicians
are not speaking to the public you know
with truth and and it's absolutely all
wrong now the question is you know how
do we do that and the diminishing world
for journalists you know newspapers are
diminishing the actual reality of
becoming a journalist and sustaining a
job as a journalist is very difficult as
well which is partly why documentary is
one answer especially when most people's
information is getting shorter and
shorter and shorter documentary gets
longer and longer and longer to find
truth me as a minister for culture and
democracy one of my I mean the greatest
responsibility I have is to create
preconditions for you to scrutinize me
for all of us that love democracy we
must we must love and respect your
analysts that success that we allow us
yeah because that's the best I can
critical a door for making democracy
strong and vibrant and how do you create
those preconditions I mean I by having
working on the final situation the truth
against journalists make sure that we
have a rule of law that will protect
journalists and so on and so forth there
are a lot of things we need to do even
in Sweden to be able to protect our
journalists so they can be this
democracy god how would you how would
you value the this situation in Sweden
now he spoke about oxygen is it enough
oxygen in in the the air in in sweden at
the moment i think no i think that we of
course i mean you can see differences
between different parts of the world and
different countries but I'm worried
about the oxygen in in Sweden and I'm
but I I have so much hope in journalists
are following the journalists internal
discussions very closely where I see
that you have yourself regularly how you
you discuss what you do between
colleagues and I think that's so
important and that we have this this
system of really being professional
journalists that when you also
scrutinized yourself right now as we
didn't have a very interesting debate
between different newspapers and
journalists and what they do and what
choices they make when it comes for
example putting name and faces on people
that that some people say everybody know
who is it but they haven't been in front
of their the law and so on and so forth
so well I think we need more oxygen that
we need we'll have this debate in public
short final question you mentioned that
documentaries may become even more
important when you see what is happening
in the media society would you like to
elaborate on that and it would be
interesting to hear here Alice's comment
on that as well
documentary gonna save us when the
traditional media's are going down I
don't I've talked to me if you are going
to save us but I think to build on what
Joanna said it's a very useful platform
to to you know journalism is it's not
heading into in with the lack of so
again with the way lack of funding for
newspapers documentary allows long form
journalism to flourish and right now
with platforms like Netflix we have a
fantastic flourishing of documentary and
so it's I think it's a really great time
for the platform to help hold power to
account now that's more money to
documentaries making sure that
documentary in Sweden anyway are getting
more money but I I think that
documentary as an art form also it's
important when it comes to giving us the
people
or perspectives more views I mean the
picture as a tool is very strong in
telling stories and telling other people
stories so we need more documentaries in
Our Lives more documentaries in our
lives
let's go conquer Orlando for mine see
that you are my mother to go thank you
so much for this
[Applause]